cher mais auparavant le tour de
l'actualité de ce mercredi avec d'abord
la situation en nouvelle-calédonie qui
nous a permis de suivre un débat fort
intéressant à l'assemblée nationale ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas un débat
qui s'inscrivait dans une séance de
questions d'actualité c'est à dire la
procédure qui permet aux députés
d'interpeller les ministres qui leur
répondent immédiatement avec à face à
face au sommet puisque l'ancien
président giscard d'estaing intervenait
pour la première fois depuis son retour
au palais bourbon c'est le premier
ministre qui lui a répondu monsieur
fabius qui a notamment indiqué qu'un
débat sur la nouvelle calédonie aurait
lieu dans les quinze jours à venir
ecoutez-le échanges entre l'ancien
président de la république et l'actuel
premier ministre la question est de
savoir
être pour revenu sur l'application de ce
statut comme il y avait évolué plus avec
révolter et vous êtes revenu à la fois
dans la lettre et dans l'esprit
d'abord pendant son application vous
êtes garant de la sécurité des libertés
publiques
monsieur bré ministe la proposition à la
suivante puisque up pour vous pour votre
gouvernement
l'autodétermination par est appelé en
écho l'indépendance
permettez aux néo calédonien de pouvoir
exercer librement leur soit et que nous
puissions préparer nuti le souhaitons
avec peu
puis l'autre formule un autre statut une
départementalisation progressive et
façon en effet des privilèges mais en
même temps assurant l'égalité
progressive des changes de toutes les
communautés la communauté kanak les
choses et la communauté français vivent
sur place et mettez je vois au moment de
l'autodétermination le soin entre ces
deux options
qu'est ce que le gouvernement souhaite
dans cette affaire
éviter les affrontements
trouver une solution qui respecte les
droits légitimes de chaque communauté
et je voudrais si vous voulez bien parmi
les nombreux commentaires
que ce difficile dossier a fait jaillir
vous en citer un
qui m'a plus particulièrement touchées
la difficulté du problème ne date pas de
mai 1981 et donc tous les gouvernements
depuis ces deux dernières décennies ont
une part de responsabilité
d'autre part parce que rien ne doit être
fait ou dit qu'ils puissent prendre le
climat plus tendu
ce texte et de monsieur stasi
je constate monsieur le président
giscard d'estaing aujourd'hui vous ne
pouvez pas pas encore être d'accord avec
le gouvernement de la france je souhaite
que vous soyez au moins d'accord avec
monsieur station oui je